but it's going to be a nice friday it's
going to be a great weekend we're clear
out there right now and it's pretty
chilly we've got a mix of 30s and 40s i
wanted to share a beautiful photo you
know they don't all have to be mountains
and beautiful vistas this was a great
shot by john salvi earlier in the week
it's flamingo and boulder highway
during his morning commute look at the
colors in the sky just so pretty and
then you've got the stop lights and
everything it's just
a really cool shot and you can share any
of your weather photos with us pix pix
8newsnow.com and we had some wonderful
ones of the sunset back at the beginning
of the week with all the clouds and we
may have a nice stellar sunset like that
again tonight as we'll get clouds coming
in the afternoon hours and through the
evening so if you have some and you take
some good shots send them to us we do
have a lot of 40s around the valley
upper 30s at nellis 39 at seven hills
and it's been windy at kyle canyon
not as windy up at lea canyon but kyle
canyons had 30 plus mile an hour winds
we do expect some windy conditions
through the mountains today 52 for the
high that will be dropping into the 30s
through the day by the way lee canyon
has the chris ruby cup tomorrow it's
competition but it's fun it's a
snowboard and skiing tomorrow they do a
slalom course and if you sign up to be a
nevada organ donor they'll cover the
cost of registration they're going to
have live music and food and all kinds
of fun up there temps at lee canyon
tomorrow will be in the low 40s so just
dress warm but we should have lots of
good sunshine for saturday and sunday
the northwest under more rain and snow
here are the clouds that will be coming
our way and they'll cover la san diego
and even phoenix will get a taste of
those clouds later today into tonight
man it's cold across the northern plains
the upper midwest i mean we're talking
wind chills that are still in the minus
20s
right now chicago's dropped below zero
minneapolis is in the minus teens and
there's been snow again on the east
coast traveled in from tennessee and
kentucky but new york boston all those
areas have a lot of snow upstate new
york has seen a lot of snow in the last
several hours i think we had some video
of it but
it's really scenic it's beautiful to
look at but when you got to get out
there in the morning for your commute
and get all that snow off your car and
shovel your driveway it's not as fun
to work in it as it is to look at it or
play in it like up at mount charleston
so the folks back there have a little
rougher commute this morning look at the
snow on the basketball backstop all
right so we've got snow and rain in the
northwest and clouds coming in for us
across the southwest but we'll stay dry
temperatures will reach for the 60s oh
there's mount charleston again didn't
mean to put that in twice for the valley
we'll look for mid 60s if we can make it
today we won't have the winds in the
valley like they've been having up there
at kyle canyon early this morning good
sunny skies for the weekend temperatures
do start to slide as we get through
saturday and sunday a little bit with
clouds coming back on monday and a few
clouds around next week but no rain for
us yet in the forecast for the new year